one of the most important things that
everybody listening to this podcast
should be doing
is i'm just going to be completely
honest i've never said this before as
i've come to learn even more so this
year
and as i hope i'll continue to realize
in 2021
the ultimate goal is
[Music]
this is part two of my look back at 2020
and i look forward at 2021. if you've
not listened to part one
go back and listen to that first um in
this episode i'm going to continue to
look at
the ways that i want to improve in 2021
and the ways that i know i went wrong or
could have approved all the lessons that
i've learned
in 2020 so without further ado i'm
stephen bartlett and this is the diver
ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
the next point in my diary is one that
i've banged on about in this podcast
like a broken record but i just
i just know how important it's been for
me in 2020 that i'm just gonna
give it just a couple of more sentences
and this is that word consistency
um if you're watching youtube um you'll
see that i've been
very consistent with the gym this year
but it's it stretches across all facets
of my life
i i had this real revelation i think it
was actually when
um it was two things happen at the same
time it's when i hit a million followers
on instagram
and i thought about the reason why i
achieved that
and i realized that it was literally
just posting every single day and
learning and trying
and looking at the analytics and getting
a little bit better and then posting
again
for years and years and years and when i
saw that my first 900 posts had got me
10 000 followers and the next 900 posts
had got me 1.1 million
and then i started reading about
compounding interest and how consistency
and money
um achieves the same effect and it's
really all about time
and patience and showing up every day
with your investments
and as i reflected on the slight edge
which is one of my favorite books of all
time which talks about how the small
things
repeated over time are much more
powerful than the singular big decisions
we make
then i've just fallen in love with this
idea of consistency and and
the reason why i'm talking about it
again on this podcast is because it pops
in my head every day
and it pops in my head at the times when
it most needs to pop in my head like the
gym last
night i'm sat here i'm sat in my uh my
apartment it's midnight i'm thinking i'm
[ __ ] tired
i've gotta wake up on saturday as i am
right now and be consistent and do this
podcast at 8 00 am on saturday morning
but i also need to go to the gym and so
that voice creeps in and says
[ __ ] it just go to bed right [ __ ] it off
but then this new voice
appears in my mind these days and it
goes steve but remember the power of
consistency
and it's these moments it's these
moments where you don't want to do it
that are going to make all the
difference
and it's these moments where people
typically bail
and so it must be these moments that are
most valuable these these must be the
moments that most people don't overcome
and so i drag my ass up every day and go
to the gym and then when i'm at the gym
as it was last night i'm sat there
thinking bro you're tired right i had my
pre-workout but
um it started to wear off it's 1am and
i'm thinking steve you've done five sets
i know you usually do six but just pack
it in and go home now but then this
voice shows up again and goes steve
consistency remember the power of
consistency you've seen it all year in
your life
just do that last set and again as i
said it's
um i'm recording this podcast on
saturday we woke up
all of the team not just myself for 8
a.m to do this because we know we have
to be consistent with this podcast
historically we've not been but you
we've seen this year
the power of being consistent the
podcast this year is doing three times
more downloads and listeners and it's
growing quickly
than it did in all previous years where
i wasn't consistent
and this voice shows up in my head i
don't i don't want to wake up
i got into bed at what 3 a.m last night
i woke up this morning at what 5 a.m to
start writing this podcast and to go
through my notes and stuff like that
like two hours sleep i don't have to be
doing this [ __ ]
right but i know that the goal i want to
achieve with the podcast and with all
these other areas of my life like my
health my fitness
my business depend on me
being consistent especially in the
moments where every part of my
body you can probably tell i'm pretty
tired now if you're watching me on
youtube
tells me not to be um and that's why i'm
just the biggest evangelist of
consistency and listen if you're bored
of it
then uh then good because hopefully
you'll be so bored that you might give
it a try
the next point in my diary is one that i
actually talked about
um when the pandemic first broke out and
if you guys listened to the podcast i
did i think it's called the
dealing with uncertainty or unexpected
chaos or something like that
um i did this in april time when the
pandemic first struck
um and the topic is optimism pro
and proactivity and these two words are
so incredibly important to me i learned
a very valuable lesson this year when
you know our business in march was
absolutely smashed i think we lost 50
of our revenue in that month we bounced
back even stronger and better than ever
but in that particular month we
were absolutely [ __ ] right and none of
us knew at that time how long this
[ __ ] was going to last and how long
our business was going to be smashed for
and you're faced with a bunch of options
and moments like that and i always speak
about this burning room analogy i call
it
if a room is on fire you typically have
two types of people you have one type of
person who will literally just say
the room is on fire oh my god the room
is on fire oh my god the room is on fire
oh my god the room's on fire and
eventually the [ __ ] flames will
engulf them and they're dead right
and then you have another type of person
who's in the same room with the same
people
and they won't need to tell you the
room's on fire because clearly the room
is on fire and there's no
upside in dwelling upon the fact that
we're all about to burn down that type
of person
will have optimism and proactivity they
will be solely focused on making a plan
and galvanizing others to feel the
optimism to deliver upon that plan
they will say here is how we get out of
the room right they don't dwell on the
fact that we're all about to burn to
death because it's a waste of time
and that time and energy will take away
from the
um the chance of the solution working
out and when the pandemic here
we could have gone one of either way uh
one of two ways is the business we could
have dwelled
negatively or we can galvanize the
troops and figure out with optimism and
proactivity how we're getting out of it
and it always transpires in life in all
of those moments where i thought we were
gonna [ __ ] burn down
that optimism and proactivity are much
of the reason we survived and we look
back on it and it wasn't actually that
bad
and this is a this is a rule for any
time in your life when you encounter
those moments where it feels like
you are finished and i tell you what we
all had them this year but
you've got more coming because that's
the nature of life when you encounter
those moments where it feels like it's a
wrap
um you have to lean towards optimism and
you have to lean towards creating
a plan to get out of there anything else
anything else detracts from the solution
and also
as it relates to your friends and as it
relates to the people you keep around
you and the people you hire into your
businesses
and the people you call your your
business partners when you start your
company
you need to do everything in your power
to avoid people who are pessimistic
and who refuse to be proactive in those
situations they are
baggage they really really really are
baggage
and you're gonna have to carry them and
there's a lot of [ __ ] you have to carry
in life right whether
it's in your personal life or in your
career so you want to limit the amount
of weight you're carrying and those
people that are negative that
dwell on all the things that could go
wrong that are
um that are quick to cast to
catastrophize about
the fact that we're all [ __ ] those
people are tremendous burdens and
in 2021 carry less of those people
people don't like when i say this
because i listen they you know what they
say to me and i'm just gonna be
completely honest and i've never said
this before
but every time i start talking about
negative people people misconstrue the
point
um as i'm talking about people that
suffer with their mental health they say
steve well
you know people have depression and you
can't give up on them completely true
i'm not talking about those people with
mental illnesses i'm talking about
people that have a
disposition to always see the negativity
as a reflection of their own opinion of
themselves or
what they've been through they have a
predisposition
to point at the negative to to
immediately gravitate towards the
reasons why things can't happen
those people are [ __ ] burdens and i
tell you what they say you become
like the five people you hang around
with the most right so unbelievably true
so unbelievably true maybe the greatest
influence on all of our lives
maybe even more so than social media and
that's one hell of an influence
is those four or five people that you
let really close in your circle
and um it's almost unavoidable that
you'll become
somewhat of a replica or a clone of them
when i was
14 years old i became an indie and i
started listening to the kooks and
arctic monkeys and i started wearing
skinny jeans and a little fred pet fred
perry polo shirt
because the five people that i was
closest to will wear all those clothes
by 16 i was a total chav right i had
like ditched all of that stuff i was
stone island i was going to the football
match wearing caps and stuff probably
being a bit of a football hooligan
because the five closest people to me at
a very influential age i will say
were like that and now i'm 27 28
i can't remember my own bloody age now
that i'm 28 years old i
although i've shaken off a lot of that
desire to conform to the you know the
people around me
i'm still getting my energy getting my
my world view getting my perspective
from the people around me and
i you know i've done a very good job
and i will continue to do a very good
job of shaking off those burdens
and i think you should too because those
people even though people will get
offended when i say this
they are burdens they're absolute
burdens their burdens in your companies
their burdens in your social life their
burdens and your family
and you your life is too short for you
to carry burdens so don't carry them
and it doesn't matter if that hurts
people's feelings it's the truth don't
carry burdens you're going to die so
you know you don't you want to go far
you want to be slowed down by carrying
large
human shaped backpacks
the next point in my diary i've just
written if you're easily provoked you
are
easily controlled and in 2021 please
make composure
your superpower i am i've been very
guilty of this you know i did this
podcast and i tell people you know
all these philosophical ideas i have and
all the things i figured out about
myself and how to implement them into
their lives but i still
find myself falling foul of all the same
[ __ ] nonsense that i evangelize
about which is
part of being an imperfect human being
right and i still find myself being very
easily provoked at times whether it's in
a romantic context or
by some just totally random twitter
account right or some random dm i still
find myself being
provoked too often something that i've
definitely definitely improved on i'd
say i'm 100 better than i was last year
but um but in most facets of life if
you're so if you're susceptible to being
provoked emotionally
if you're someone that is quite
sensitive to um
to to someone's comments or to a
stranger because of typically because of
some
insecurity you have and that's a
completely separate point if
if when you are provoked you ask
yourself that question [ __ ] why was i
offended by that
asking myself that question has helped
me identify many of my own insecurities
because
if some little random egg emoji twitter
account can
can genuinely change your mood with a
180 characters or a couple of words
then that speaks to some kind of
internal insecurity or vulnerability
which you probably should address
because as i said if you're easily
provoked you're easily controlled and
it's it's not their words that are
controlling you it's that insecurity
that's still driving you
um one of the things i'm trying to work
very hard on this year
this coming year in 2021 is to be less
easily provoked and in fact the way that
i
i imagine i'll go about that is by
addressing more of my
insecurities i've done a really good job
though you know
i don't think i have that many
insecurities left i still have
hundreds but we're down from probably
millions right like there's probably a
million things that i was insecure about
to some degree um but yeah
i'll let you think about that and the
next point i've written in my diary is
one that definitely applies to everybody
and it's a lesson that i've learned
um over the last couple years especially
being a young entrepreneur that started
my first business at 18 years old and
that always was dealing with
older people that knew more and that
were in some cases double my age
i've just written the easiest way to
remove disrespectful people from your
life is to start by respecting yourself
i know for sure that there's a direct
correlation a very very very strong
undeniable correlation between the
amount of respect you have for yourself
and the amount of respect you get from
everybody else especially as it relates
to business
especially as it relates to personal
relationships especially as it relates
to
romantic relationships i know that at
certain moments in my life the reason
why i've garnered the respect i have
is because i have intentionally
faked being a bit of a tough guy
and i think that kind of stayed with me
i'm going to try and explain this
i've had to deal with some very
successful
old experienced wise people in business
that are many years ahead of me
and if i hadn't been a fake
tough guy and
sometimes cussed and sometimes been a
bit
you know antagonistic and a bit a bit
violent with the protection of my
boundaries
i know for sure i wouldn't be
where i am today because
those people will respect me as much as
they think i respect
myself and i've learned this lesson not
just through my own observations of my
own life but also
people around me people who are also my
age and people that i've watched deal
with those same people
and i've managed to watch those same
people those old very experienced
business people totally disrespect
these people because they don't respect
themselves and they're not
coming with that same i know my value
you're gonna
[ __ ] respect me or i'm going to
um violently protect my boundaries type
of energy
and it was just a lesson i've learned
and it applies to all facets of life
even at those outside of business in
your relationships with your partner
they'll typically respect you typically
not always some people are a little bit
nicer but they'll typically respect you
as much as you demand
to be respected through the presidents
as you set
the standards you set through what you
allow and what you accept and it's just
a really important lesson
the easiest way to remove disrespect
from your life is to start by respecting
yourself
and the next point in my diary is one
that i've um i've learned through the
hiring process of hiring
almost a thousand people we have some
about 750 active employees at social
chain i've not hired all of them but um
as i've hired people but also in my sort
of close friendship groups i've learned
this very very important lesson
about self-awareness and i've just
written in my diary if someone can't
accurately identify
what their own flaws are then they have
the most dangerous flaw of them all
which is a total lack of self-awareness
and i'll be honest the people who i'm
most impressed by the people that i see
achieve the most success and
those that are often the most happiest
or at least those that appear to be the
most in control
of their life are those that can tell me
all the ways that they're [ __ ] up
and i i have conversations i remember
one particular conversation with a
friend who i shan't name because
they will not like it and they i know
they listen to this podcast where
i ask them their flaws and as their
friend i think as
friends we can always identify glaringly
obvious flaws in our friends we know
what they're good and bad at sometimes
and unfortunately more than they do
and my friends sat there and went oh
nothing yeah couldn't think of anything
right could think of all the things they
were good at but couldn't identify their
own flaws
and it struck me in that moment that
they had the most sort of debilitating
dangerous floor of them all
which is that lack of self-awareness i
think everybody
should have a very very clear idea and
also brag about the fact that they know
what their [ __ ]
at and what their insecurities are and
how they're damaged and how their
childhood [ __ ] them up
i think those are the people that i bet
on the most
those are the people that are conscious
about the things that might hold them
back and therefore
can do something about them if anyone
you encounter in an interview
or on a date or wherever a colleague at
work can't tell you accurately what
their flaws are how they're [ __ ] up
or what they're not good at or what
their recurring toxic thoughts and
habits and patterns are
then that's deeply concerning because
perfection definitely doesn't exist
right we know that for sure
but we also know that a lack of
self-awareness certainly does
if someone can't accurately identify
what their own flaws are then they have
the most dangerous flaw of them all
a total lack of self-awareness in part
one of this podcast
i talked about huel in my partnership
with huel and the impact it's had on my
life
i've actually got one of my best friends
one of my top four best friends
has suffered for the last how many years
probably about the last two decades with
his diet
he's got like a mild eating disorder and
because of that
he's been fairly unhealthy and fairly
overweight for the last two decades
right
and he came across hugh three years ago
i
have always been worried about my friend
because if you eat just crisps every day
you are going to it's going to catch up
on you at some point he came across
huell
and the guy lost so much [ __ ] weight
and now has a six-pack he actually still
eats domino's pizzas which is quite
strange
but he says that hule is the reason that
he now has this like
beautiful six-pack he's skinny you know
him jack don't you
you know do you know what i'm talking
about actually i'm talking about yeah
and
he attributes that to huel i've seen you
know the upside of having a
nutritionally complete diet
some of us are too busy to have it some
of us are we don't like fruit enough or
we don't like this enough and that is
where heal comes in
it's changed my life has changed the
life of my best friends
and um i know if you're one of those
people like me
too busy to eat well or at least that's
what they tell themselves and who can
change yours too
the next point in my diary is about
labels and i've just written in my diary
resisting my own labels society and
culture
and instagram is very very quick to tell
you to go and find
your passion or to go and find your
thing or what you
are or who you are as if it was like
pre-ordained or pre-determined for you
before you were born
and this like i think this this this
fuels this culture of labeling but we
also have this
innate desire to fit and to be
identified and to fit in
so we search for labels that that make
us make sense
and this year i quit my business i was
the ceo
of socialchain and as i am as i left
my business i left with that label it's
what the world knows me as it's my
sort of adopted but also like earned
identity
i am a ceo of a social media business
and as i reflected upon that as i was
out in the jungle in costa rica writing
my book which you can now pre-order
happy sexy millionaire on amazon
um i started writing about this idea of
labels and how
really really dangerous they are we all
have labels and i don't mean just labels
as in work titles i mean some of us
have labeled ourselves poor we've
labeled ourselves as a poor person or a
rich person
mum dad tall short fat black
white these are all labels we've given
ourselves ceo
intern creative right these are all
labels
i don't think any of them really help
when i left social chain
you know typically what you'd think okay
successful social media ceo oh he's
gonna go and start another social media
business
and i just thought but why i've done
that i've achieved that i've built a
great social media company
i don't have to be my label what what i
am fundamentally
if you want to get down to the the the
sort of fundamentals is like
i'm a set of skills and experiences and
a set of skills and experiences that
should theoretically be able to be
applied to any
um challenge that i put myself to
and if i if i if i if i just focus on
these labels
ceo social media business there's a high
chance i might
lose some of the joy of life which is
the spontaneity and the exploration i
might start to just live out my label
i think a lot of people do that they
live out the label that they are a mum
and only a mum and they can't be
anything more
or they are a poor person or they are a
this or that or whatever
and these labels i think are more
restrictive than they are beneficial
so what i said to myself this year upon
leaving social chain was that i was just
going to resist all my [ __ ] labels
and trying to live life on those on that
basis
because these labels are just a bunch of
society
induced given [ __ ] and so
the first thing i did was obviously the
diary of a ceo
right so the diver ceo live live show is
a big theatrical performance
you guys that haven't bought tickets i
really think you should have bought
tickets because it's such an amazing
thing
it's basically like a theatrical
performance i'm giving the game away a
little bit here
but i wanted to create like a theatrical
performance because
because why not because that's not
because i'm creative right
the next thing i did was write a book
again and does not in line with the
labels of being a social media ceo
every word of that book no ghostwriters
because again like i'm creative and i
have ideas these are the fundamental
constitutes of who i am then i started
to learn how to dj
because that's interesting and fun as
well and then i started working in
biotech because that's interesting and i
can apply myself to that as well
and i've basically for the last six
months completely
resisted all of the things that
my labels tell me i should do
um and i really think it's a much better
way to live
i think there's this real sort of
insecurity and comfort seeking nature in
all of us
that tells us to go and be the thing we
just were and to stay in our lane and i
think the danger is that if i start to
believe that because i've spent the last
10 years doing this thing on social
media and being a ceo
that the next 10 years has to be the
same or that my comfort or happiness or
i i'm only allowed to be my past
i think my life will be really like
one-dimensional and shallow
one of my goals for the next year that
i've already started to implement
is to resist my labels and to just focus
on the fact that i am nothing
i am just a guy with a bunch of skills
who can apply those skills to a bunch of
different things that he might enjoy
and i think a lot of the time in fact
that's why
people don't quote unquote find their
passion not that it is
some easter egg that's waiting at the
bottom of your garden for you to find
but because they think too narrowly
about what and who they are they go to
one school
with a certain sort of economic
situation socio-economic situation
and then they start looking at five
things and saying well i don't like any
of these five things
when you broaden your approach and when
you stop
living your life through your own labels
i think you can discover how many
different things you love and
and for me variety is the spice of life
and
labels are the antithesis of variety
they are
pigeonholing they are excitement killing
and they are unnecessary they're one of
the things in life that
aims to guide you but paradoxically will
lead you astray
okay so the next lesson which i i felt
like i have somewhat of an obligation to
talk to you guys about because i know
there's going to be some of you
listening to this podcast
that aren't doing this and haven't
probably even considered it yet because
you just don't think it's important
um one of the most important things that
everybody listening to this podcast
should be doing and i say this as
someone that does this
and spends at least two hours a day
doing this is investing your money
um there's a there's a couple of
important sort of sub points to this
find ways to spend less find ways to
save more
and find ways to invest even more and
when when we talk about investing
typically you think of investing as
something that other people do right
like
wealthy people that live in you know
canary wharf in london or new york city
run around in suits waving pieces of
paper at the stock exchange
and investing their money but genuinely
genuinely genuinely
if you learn the habit of investing your
money now
it can have a completely
disproportionate impact on how
free your life is in 10 20 or 30 years
time
and when i talk about investing people
will often come back to me and say well
i just don't understand it right that's
how i just don't i just don't know
and i think it's like isn't it tragic
that in a in
an era where we have the sum total of
the world's information at our
fingertips
and with 5g internet so we can get it in
a in a second
that not understanding something which
is actually quite simple if you just
gave a couple of hours to it
is the barrier that's stopping a lot of
people
from ever building their wealth and like
living hand to mouth is like okay
if you're earning a decent salary but if
you want to build wealth which is
ultimately
freedom i think of money as just like
freedom coins
and you're letting i just don't
understand it because you've never
googled it and never tried
be the barrier be the first hurdle that
you can't even jump
for me that's a great shame and i did
this for a long time i did this for
maybe 25 years i think i started
investing capital when i was about 26
years old
but up until 25 years i just thought
well investing is for other people right
people that aren't like me and my thing
is i can i need to make more money
and then just save it no your money can
act like
like soldiers it can go out every day
take prisoners and come back
with more right and that's what you
should be doing with your money if you
don't know how to invest
and um because you don't understand or
you don't understand cryptocurrency or
bitcoin or whatever
google it please i swear to god if there
was one
investment of your time that stands to
make you
multiple riches over the next 10 or 20
years
it's just learning what this investing
thing is and it could quite
literally take you 10 hours
to understand 10 hours to genuinely
multiply your future wealth and you're
letting i don't understand it
stand in the way of you and your chances
of being wealthy i don't actually know
how someone can be wealthy without
understanding investing
with outside of winning the lottery or
starting a very big business that ends
up being sold or acquired or whatever or
you know when i'm and i'm keyword here
not rich i'm talking about wealthy
right but i also know how someone who is
earning a wage a decent wage
can become a
multi-multi-multi-multi-millionaire
by just doing the most basic form of
investing
but the problem is they don't teach you
this stuff in school so this is one of
the things in life where
you're gonna have to do it yourself
you're gonna have to go and put those 10
hours in
my brother said to me one day he said um
i was talking about you know what to do
with my money i was like bro i'm gonna
my brother's an investment manager an
investment banker
i said bro i'm gonna um i'm gonna buy a
house and he turned to me said steve if
everybody knows how to do it the returns
are low
and he said how many people do you know
that are buying houses and that know how
to buy a house and said everybody i know
everybody in social channel 700 people
some people have two or three houses he
went then don't do that
he said if you want a higher return you
have to go and do the thing that most
people
don't know how to do and he went
investing most people don't ever bother
to teach themselves about investing
we all typically live in this world
where um the narrative is you you go to
university whatever you get a job and
then you go and get that mortgage and
you buy a house that's the path
so just like thinking logically it does
make sense that there would be greater
returns
doing the thing that nobody's told you
about or that is off-piste right
and that's what investing is and we're
we're seeing a real renaissance moment
at the moment with young people
old people who would never invest before
because of apps like revolut and monzo
and
how easy it's become to invest start to
get into investing but also because the
bitcoin
that pulls a ton of people in and i just
want i i would just i think if i could
give you a piece of value if there's
something you could come away from the
podcast and think you know what
that was the day where i started
investing then i think that would be a
tremendous
um a tremendous thing that i've done
because if i get to get one person
listening to this podcast to put in
those hours into google
how to invest and to get the hargreave
lands down app or
an investment app on their phone and
just start putting 10 pounds in every
single month into
the index funds or the s p 500 or into
facebook stock or whatever it might be
then i think the habit you'll learn and
the rules you'll learn about money will
change your life in the life of your
kids forever so i think that's a
i just couldn't not say it today the
last point in my diary this week kind of
goes against what you typically hear
from people
there's a narrative which is circulating
social media at the moment about
burnout and about you know don't work
too hard because it'll destroy your
mental health and all of those kinds of
things
but i just want to bring a bit of nuance
and realism to this debate
um hard work does really really matter
and
i am people like don't like when i say
this because
they they think that i'm i'm pushing
that hustle porn star thing
there's a caveat to this like hard work
really really matters if you want to
achieve
really great things and the reason why
i'm comfortable with saying that
and with it feeling true is because i
can't think
of one person that i know
founder of a company um philanthropist
activist that has achieved really great
things
scientists without really hard work
even the you know the the absolute
astonishing job they've done with the
vaccine with operation warp speed where
they managed to get this vaccine done
in a fraction of the time with urgency i
can't think of one person
i know that's been wildly successful
that hasn't worked really really hard
not one so as much as tempting as it is
and i know for a fact that if i do a
tweet saying hard work doesn't matter
take care of your dog and
take your wife for dinner i know if i
tweet that i'll get
[ __ ] loads of retweets but it's just not
true it and like
i know people don't like when i say this
but can you think of one person in your
life
that has been extraordinarily successful
in like building a company or that sort
of initial uphill graph that it takes to
achieve great things
that hasn't worked really really really
hard
i can't and so i think that's important
but but
here's the thing hard work
at the expense of all of the other
things in life that make life worth
living
family relationships your dog
hard work at the expense of those things
is illogical
because as i've come to learn even more
so this year
and as i hope i'll continue to realize
in 2021
the ultimate goal is happiness
that is the north star that is the
sort of prism in which you should look
to make all of your decisions right
not success not being really really rich
not being
happy sexy millionaire like i wrote in
my diary 18 years old
it's happiness that is the north star
and if hard work or your career or your
job or any of that stuff
compromises your happiness then it's not
worthwhile
but i don't want to lie to you and i
wouldn't be sat here now you wouldn't be
listening to my podcast i wouldn't have
all this stuff i wouldn't be in this
penthouse in london with
these people around me if i didn't work
really really [ __ ] hard for a long
period of time
but i managed to do it and i managed to
maintain my focus
on that north star which was being happy
and that's really the nuance that this
debate needs
and i genuinely believe that anybody
that tries to tell you otherwise
has liked your face thank you so much
for listening
we're back again next week with an
amazing amazing guest on this podcast
and
2021 is the year of the diary of a ceo
it's the year where we're gonna deliver
a podcast every single monday
and i'm gonna own your monday um we're
gonna be consistent and we're we're
urgently stepping up our level of
ambition with this show
thank you so much for listening i feel
like i didn't i i don't say that enough
to all of you guys it means a ton
to me and honestly there'll be little
moments where i'm in the street or in
the gym or someone will say something
about the podcast
and it just puts this tremendous fire
under my belly to continue to do it
because we're waking up early saturday
mornings 7am
5am sometimes to record this show it
requires a huge commitment and the
driving force behind that commitment is
all of your feedback
if you're listening on youtube hit the
subscribe button if you're listening on
the
the spotify or the podcast or hit the
subscribe button it means a ton to me
and it's more fuel for this movement um
and yeah it's the reason why we can keep
bringing you these episodes
and i'll see you again next week for
another installment of the driver ceo